Nathalie bonjour vous êtes notre
correspondante à Pékin avez-vous plus
d'informations sur le déroulé de cette
visite à Kiev
là où je vous parle nous avons aucune
information sur les rencontres
potentielles de l'hémisphère chinois lil
way avec ses homologues Ukrainiens ni de
confirmation officielle de la part des
chinois sur même son arrivée on Ukraine
les grands médias détache chinois n'ont
pas non plus publier des papiers sur le
sujet la situation sécuritaire pourrait
expliquer cela mais on avait vu dans le
passé quand d'autres émissaires
importants arrivent en Ukraine parfois
ils font des promenades de dernier
minute devant les caméras et les micros
de journalistes peut-être que Lil Way
est arrivé très tard mardi soir et que
ce mercredi et c'est des placements
seraient rendus un peu plus public ou
bien on aura une couverture dans la
foulée mais pour l'instant ce que je
peux vous dire que ici en Chine la
couverture reste plutôt discrète c'est
Pékin manifestement prudent par rapport
à cette visite puis ce mardi à l'autre
bout du monde à l'autre côté du monde
Cyril Rama posa le président
sud-africain a annoncé un projet de plan
de paix africain et n'oublions pas le
président Brésil Lula aussi veut créer
un club de paix de pays non alignés pour
promouvoir la paix en Ukraine il est
donc clair que la Chine n'est pas le
seul pays à vouloir mener les
négociations
la Chine n'a pas encore publiquement
et qu'elle a
pour comme elle appelle mais on a un
document de deux points la Chine a
publié ça il y a presque 3 mois c'est un
document qui détaille sa position sur la
guerre en Ukraine c'est un document
plutôt vague qui contient
essentiellement des déclarations plutôt
non controversées telles que respecter
la souveraineté de tous les pays cesser
les hostilités lancer les pour parler de
paix etc etc bien entendu ce qui serait
plus compliqué ça serait de définir les
termes de ce cesser le feu déterminer
qui serait prêt à renoncer quoi et à
quand et à quel prix pour l'Ukraine et
ses alliés occidentaux les problèmes des
tentatives chinoises c'est la relation
entre Pékin et Moscou la Chine soutien
économiquement son voisin et la Chine
n'a même pas encore condamné
publiquement l'invasion russe ceci dit
pour certains la relation cette relation
aussi nos russes pourrait bien être le
principal avantage de la Chine le
président français Emmanuel Macron la
présidente de la commission
parmi ceux qui appellent à ce que Pékin
utilise justement en son influence sur
Vladimir Poutine
pour France 24 merci beaucoup yena en
suivra évidemment se déplacement c'est
déplacements de l'hémisphère chinois on
en revient assez